my name is Chris morale and I worked in
social media marketing and content
marketing for the last 10 years or so
for brands including Fitbit Clif Bar
Sony Playstation and now here at Udacity
when you're setting up your ad campaigns
it's really important to think about
what keywords you're going to target so
if you're developing a fitness app it
might not make sense to target fitness
as a keyword because it's really
competitive it might be really expensive
it might make sense to target a phrase
like hit the gym or go outside something
that might get you a little better
return because the cost is low and it's
a little less competitive with bigger
brands you have to get creative with
keywords and AD terms five six years ago
when these social channels are really
getting off the ground things weren't
quite as expensive there wasn't a lot of
competition with big brands but now
everybody's advertising on social so you
have to start getting you know a little
bit creative with the keywords and your
campaigns to get better returns and to
compete against people that might be
advertising the same words as you when
we're thinking about acquiring new
customers we definitely want to make
sure our keywords are really targeted to
your your audience so you want to keep
them kind of long tail to you know if
you start bidding on really broad terms
we're thinking more farther up in the
buying cycle or the buying funnel right
so you want to be capturing a user who's
about ready to download an app for
example so maybe for example it's a
music app or music streaming app you
don't want to be targeting users who are
looking for Taylor Swift or Taylor Swift
music that's going to be too broad and
most likely they're not going to be as
likely to convert or download that app
so you want to be thinking really
specific like music streaming app or
listen to Taylor Swift music on my phone
or Taylor Swift music app something like
that and so you want to get really down
to those long tail terms when you're
acquiring new users off search because
you want to think about how people
behave on sir
both google com and Google Play there
they know what they're looking for and
so you want to be present only when
they're most likely to download that app
the other thing you want to keep in mind
is making sure your ad creatives are
relevant to your keywords so if I'm
searching for Taylor Swift music ideally
I see an ad that says listen to Taylor
Swift music 24 7 or something and so you
know having that relevancy really and
you know it makes it more likely that
your ad will perform that'll drive more
downloads capture the users I and you
also want to make it clear what the
action is so in any ad creative you want
to say download today or download the
app now something really simple like
that where the user knows if I'm going
to click on this ad it's going to be
very clear what the action is and it'll
make it easy for me to to download the
app or register for you know your
product or your service and so yeah
those are the things you want to keep in
mind is keeping the keywords in the ads
relevance and then ultimately the
landing page so obviously if i'm looking
to download or stream music or sign up
today hopefully when i click that ad it
takes me to the registration page where
i can register for your product or i can
download that app right Benton so the
the most ideal experience let's say on
my phone I'm going to search on my the
phone listen to Taylor Swift music on a
nap see your ad click on the ad then it
takes me the google play store then i
can download the app and then start
using it adwords functions as an auction
so if a user um you know is looking for
a certain type of product usually
they're going to see multiple ads and
you might wonder how do I make sure that
I show in the top position or at the top
of the page or even on that page so all
of that comes down to how well your
campaigns are set up so you want to
follow those principles that we've been
talking about and have really tightly
themed keywords that are
most relevant to your product keep your
ads really relevant to your keywords and
then ultimately your landing page is
really relevant so all of that comes
into play but then ultimately you can
use your bid and to so this would be how
much you're willing to pay for a user to
click on your ad so there are a number
of factors that determine which place
your ad is within the auction so and
which position your ad will be within
the Google results two of those main
factors that we know of it is an
algorithm so we don't know all the
factors that go into play and that's
part of google secret sauce is you know
just keeping it fair so that no
advertiser one advertiser can you know
and play the system and know how to
place their out at the top but we want
to make sure the best odds are showing
for every search query so the way that
we determine that as Google is two major
factors one is quality score and the
other is your bid and so quality score
we'll talk about that first it's a score
that combines the quality of your ad and
the quality of your keywords and the
quality of your landing page so that's
why we talked about why those three are
so important in your campaign setup
because you really want to make sure you
have a quality add that really is
descriptive of what your businesses of
what your product is and that the
landing page does actually direct to
your business and so all that goes into
playing creating a quality score which
is attached to every one of your
keywords so then when a user searches a
term that triggers your keyword that
quality score comes into play as long as
you know everything is in place and you
have a high-quality set up and then the
next thing that the auction will look at
is your bid and your bid is how much are
you willing to pay per click now every
advertiser can set that individually per
keyword and say I'm willing to pay you
know let's say I'm willing to pay and
thirty cents for a user to click on this
ad
now maybe my competitor is willing to
spend twenty cents to four click now if
my competitor and I we have now my
competitor might have a lower quality
score than I do and in that case the
combination of the quality score in the
bid will win out the auction so the
advertiser will get the first position
and with the best quality score in the
best bid now as far as bidding goes you
only have to pay the amount that will
win the auction or beat out the next
advertiser competing with you so if my
competitor was bidding twenty cents I
was bidding thirty cents that I had the
better quality score i'll only have to
pay 21 cents to be out that and that
other advertiser that's why google
functions as an auction to make it more
fair for advertisers to to decide how
much are they willing to pay but also
you don't have to pay more than the
market price per click